the following content is provided under
a creative commons license
your support will help mit
opencourseware continue to offer high
quality educational resources for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of mit courses
visit mit open courseware at ocw.mit.edu
okay so welcome back this is the second
half of our
two lectures on distributed algorithms
this week
to turn that on all right so
i'll start with a quick review this week
we're just looking at synchronous and
asynchronous distributed algorithms not
worrying about
interesting stuff like failures last
time we
looked at leader election maximal
independence set
breadth first spanning trees and we
started
looking at shortest paths trees we'll
finish that today and then we'll move on
to the main topic for today which is
asynchronous distributed algorithms
where things start getting much more
complicated because not everything is
going on
in synchronous rounds and we'll revisit
the same two problems breadth first and
shortest paths uh spanning trees
okay so a quick review uh all of our
um algorithms are
using a model that's based on an
undirected graph
we using this notation gamma for the
neighbors of a vertex
talk about the degree of a vertex we
have a process
then associated with every vertex in the
graph
and we associate communication channels
in both directions
on every edge okay
so last time we looked at synchronous
distributed algorithms in the
synchronous model
we have the processes of the graph
vertices they communicate using messages
the processes have local ports that they
know by some kind of local name
and the ports connect to their
communication channel
the algorithm executes in synchronous
rounds where in every round
every process is going to decide what to
send on all of its ports
and the messages then get put into the
channel delivered to the processes at
the other end
and everybody looks at all the messages
they get at that round all at once
and they determine a new state to
compute a new state
based on all of those arriving messages
okay um
so we started with leader election i
won't repeat the problem definition but
here's the results that we got last time
uh we looked at a special case of a
graph that's just a
simple clique and if the processes
don't have any uh distinguishing
information like unique identifiers
and they're deterministic then there's
no way to break the symmetry and you can
prove an impossibility result
that says that you can't in a
deterministic indistinguishable case you
can't guarantee to elect a leader
in this kind of a graph just as an aside
i should say that distributed computing
theory is
just filled with impossibility results
and they're all based on this limitation
of distributed computing where
each node only knows what's happening to
itself and
in its neighborhood nobody knows what's
happening in the entire
uh system so that's a very strong
limitation
and as you might expect that would make
a lot of things impossible or difficult
okay then we went on and got two
positive results a theorem that
um well an algorithm that is
deterministic but the processes have
unique identifiers
and then you can elect a leader quickly
or if you don't have unique identifiers
but you have a
probability so you can make random
choices you can essentially
choose an identifier and then it works
almost as well
with those identifiers okay then we
looked at maximal independent set
um remember what it means no two
neighbors should both be in the set but
you don't want to be able to
add any more nodes while keeping these
nodes independent in other words every
node is either in the set or has a
neighbor in the set
okay and we gave this algorithm i'm just
including it here for as a reminder
luby's algorithm which basically
goes through a number of phases in each
phase some processes
decide to join the mis and their
neighbors
decide not to join and you just repeat
this you do this
based on choosing random ideas again
okay and we proved that the theorem
correctly computes an mis and
with a good probability all the nodes
decide within only
logarithm logarithmic phases n here is
the number of nodes
okay all right then we went on to
breadth first spanning trees
here we have now a graph that already
has a leader it has a distinguished
vertex
and the process that's sitting there
knows that it's the leader
uh the processes now are going to
produce a breadth-first spanning tree
rooted
at that vertex now for the rest of the
time we'll assume unique identifiers but
the processes don't know anything about
the graph except the
their own id and their neighbor's ids
and we want the processes to eventually
output
the id of their parent and here's
uh just to repeat uh the simple
algorithm that we used
so basically it's uh processes just mark
themselves as they get included in the
tree
starts out with just the root being
marked he sends a special search message
out to his neighbors and as soon as they
get it they get marked
and pass it on so everybody gets marked
in a number of rounds that corresponds
to
their depth in the their distance from
the uh the root of the tree depth in the
tree
okay we talked about correctness in
terms of invariance so what this
algorithm guarantees is
at the end of any number r of rounds
exactly the processes at distance up to
r
are marked and the processes
that are marked have their parents
defined
and if your parents defined it's correct
it's the uid of a process
that has distance d minus one from
the root if you're at distance d your
parent should be somebody who's
correct has the correct distance d minus
one
okay we analyze the complexity time
is counting the number of rounds and
that's going to be at worst the diameter
of the network it's really
the distance from a particular vertex v0
the message complexity uh there's only
one message sent in each direction on
each edge so that's going to be only
order of the number of edges and we
talked about how you can get
child pointers this just gives you
parents but if you want to also find out
your children then every
search message should get a response
either saying you're my parent or you're
not my parent
and we can do uh termination using
converge cast and
there's some applications we talked
about as well
okay all right and then at the end of
the hour we
started talking about a generalization
of breadth first spanning trees which
adds weights
so you have shortest paths trees okay so
now you have weights on the edges
processes still have unique identifiers
they don't know anything about the graph
except their immediate neighborhood
information and they have to produce a
shortest path spanning tree
rooted at a vertex v zero
okay so you know what a spanning tree is
and shortest paths are in terms of the
total weight of the path
so now we want each node each process to
output
its parent in the shortest path and also
the distance from
the original vertex v0
okay so at the end of the hour we looked
at
a version of bellman ford which you've
already seen
for sequential algorithm as a sequential
algorithm
but as a distributed algorithm everybody
keeps track of their best guess
their best current guess of the distance
from
the initial vertex and they keep track
of their
parent on some path that gave it
this distance estimate and they keep
their unique identifier
okay so the complete algorithm now is
everybody's going to keep sending their
distance around i mean we could optimize
that but
this is simple so at every round
everybody sends
their current distance estimate to all
their neighbors they all they collect
the distance estimates from all their
neighbors
and then they do a relaxation step if
they get anything that's better than
what they had before
they look at the best new estimate they
could get so they take the minimum of
their old estimate
stop shaking good and the minimum
of uh all of the uh estimates they would
get
by looking at the incoming information
plus adding the weight
of the edge between the sender
and and the note itself okay so this way
you get a better
you may get a better estimate and if you
do you you would reset your parent
to be the sender of this
improved information and again you can
pick
if there's a tie you can pick um
any of the the nodes that sends the the
information leading to the the best
new guess you can set your parent to any
of those
okay and then this just repeats
okay so at the very end of the hour we
we showed a
an animation which i'm not going to
repeat now which basically shows how you
can get lots of
corrections there you can have
many pads that are set up that look good
after just one round but then they get
corrected
as the rounds go on so you get much
lower weight paths by having a
roundabout
multi-hop path to a node you can get a
better total cost
okay so here's where we got to last time
so now why does this work well what we
need is eventually
every process should get the correct
distance
and the parent should be its predecessor
on some shortest path
in order to prove that okay so you
always look for an invariant
something that's true at intermediate
steps of the algorithm that you can show
by induction will hold and that will
imply the result that you want at the
end
so here um what's the key invariant at
the end
of some number r of rounds
what do processes have
okay after r rounds have passed in this
kind of algorithm
what what do the estimates look like
well after one round everybody's got
their best
estimate uh that could happen on a
single
that could result from a single hot path
from v zero
after two rounds you also get the best
guesses from two hot pads
and after r rounds in general um you
have
your distance and parent corresponding
to a shortest path
chosen from among those that have it
most are hops
yes that makes sense
no yeah okay all right and
if there is no path of our hops or fewer
to get to a node they're still going to
have their distance estimate be
infinity after r rounds
so this is not a complete proof but it's
the key invariant that makes this work
so you can see that after
enough rounds corresponding to the
number of nodes for example
everybody will have the correct shortest
path
of any length okay
so the number of rounds until every
estimate stabilized all the estimates
stabilize
it's going to be n minus 1 right
because the longest simple path
to any node is going to be n minus 1 if
it goes through all the nodes
of the network before reaching it makes
sense
so if you want to make sure you have the
best estimate you have to wait n
minus 1 rounds to make sure the
information has reached you
the message complexity well that since
there's all these repeated estimates
it's no longer just
proportional to the number of edges but
you have to take into account that there
can be many new estimates sent
on on each edge in fact the way i've
written this
you just keep sending your distance at
every round so it's going to be
the number of edges times the number of
rounds so
you know you can do somewhat better than
this but it's worse than
than just the simple bfs case
okay so this is more expensive because
bfs just had
diameter rounds and this now has n
or n minus one rounds and bfs just had
one message
ever sent on each edge and now we have
to send many
comments questions
okay okay so is it clear that the time
bound really does depend on
n and not on the diameter
okay for breadth-first search it was
enough just to
um have enough rounds to correspond to
the
actual
distance and hops to each node but now
you need enough rounds to take care of
these indirect pads that might go
through
many nodes but still end up with a
shorter
with a smaller total weight okay so is
it clear to everybody why the bound
depends on
n actually the animation that i had last
time
showed uh how there were lots of
corrections and and
you had enough you had rounds that
depended on the total number of nodes
yes
yeah um but like could you like keep
track of like
uh each round if if the values if any of
the guys didn't
relax so like if you if everything stops
changing after less than n rounds
you might not have to okay so you're
asking about termination
ah okay well so that's probably the next
slide
first let's deal with the child pointers
and we'll come back to termination okay
so first this just gives you your
parents if you want your children you
can
do the same thing that we did last time
when a process gets a message
and the message doesn't make the sender
its parent
this is not giving it an improved
distance
then the node can just respond
non-parent
but if a process receives a message that
does improve the distance it says
ah okay you are my parent but
it might have also told another node it
might have another parent another node
that previously it thought was
his parent so it has to do more work in
this case to correct the erroneous
parent information
so it has to send its previous
parent a non-parent message to correct
the previous parent message
okay so things are getting a little bit
trickier here
on the other end if somebody is keeping
track of its children it has to
make adjustments to is because things
can change during the algorithm
okay so let's say a process keeps track
of its children in some set
it has a set children okay if it gets a
non-parent message from a child
even if that child that child might be
or from a neighbor
that neighbor might be and it set
children and this could be a correction
then the process has to take that
neighbor out of the set of children
okay and suppose the process
improves its own distance well now it's
kind of starting over
it's going to send that distance to its
all of its neighbors again
and collect new information about
whether they're children or not so
the simple thing to do here is just
empty
zero out your children set and start
over now you send
your your new messages to your neighbors
and wait for them to respond again
so there's tricky bookkeeping to do to
handle corrections
as the structure of this tree changes so
getting child pointers is a little more
complicated than before
make sense okay all right so now back to
your question
uh termination um
so how do all the processes know when
the tree
is complete in fact we have a worse
problem we this problem we hit for
a breath first search but we have an
even worse problem now what is that
yeah yeah
before we had each individual node once
it
figured out who its parent was it could
just output that
and now you can figure out your parent
but it's just a guess
and you don't know when you can output
this so how does a process
even an individual process even figure
out its own parent and distance
so there's two aspects here
determination one is how do you know the
whole thing is finished
but the other one is even how do you
know when you're done with your own
parent and distance
okay well you know if you knew something
about the graph like an upper bound on
the total number of nodes then you could
just wait until that number of rounds
and be done but what if you
don't have that information about the
graph
what might you do
we yeah down the information when we
reach
the size of the graph oh maybe i think
okay what is the strategy we use for
termination for bfs
let's start with that one it's a little
easier
you did the subtree thing we call
converge cast the information
when you had a leaf he knew he was a
leaf and he could send his done
information up to his parent and that
got
converged cast up to the top of the tree
okay so can we converge cast in this
setting
turns out we can but since things are
changing
um you're going to be sending done
messages and then something might change
you might be participating in the
converged cast many times
okay so since the tree structure is
changing
the main idea is anybody can send a done
message
to its current the parent that he
the note he believes is his parent
provided
his received responses to all of its uh
distance messages so it thinks it's no
it knows who all its children are okay
so it has a current estimate of all the
children
and okay so if it knows all its children
and they have all sent him done messages
so for all your current children your
current belief or who your children are
if they've all send you
sent you done messages then you can send
a done message up the tree
okay but this can get a little more
complicated than it sounds because
you can change who your children are
so this what this means is that the same
process can be involved several times in
the converge cast
based on improving the estimates
so here's an example um
so of the kind of thing that can happen
so let's say you start out
you have these huge weights and then you
have a long path with small weights so
i zero starts out and sends
its distance information on its three
nodes three to its three neighbors
and this guy at the bottom
now has a distance estimate of 100 and
it's going to decide it's a leaf
why because when it sends
messages to its children to its
neighbors
they're not able to improve their
estimates based on the new information
that he's sending
so this guy decides that he's a leaf
right away
and he sends that information back to
node i zero on the other hand this guy
has the same estimate of a hundred
and he's n he sends out his messages to
try to find out if he's a leaf
but he finds out when he sends a message
this way that he's actually able to
improve that neighbor's estimate because
that was infinity up to
till then so he doesn't think he's a
leaf
okay so we have this one guy who thinks
he's a leaf and responds so this i zero
is sitting there
he has to wait to hear from his other
children
okay so far all right so in in the
meantime the messages are going to
eventually creep around
and this node is going to get
a smaller estimate based on the length
of that long mini hop
uh path okay so then he's going to
decide he is not a child of
i zero so he's going to tell i zero i am
i'm really not your child which means
that i zero stops waiting for it
but also this guy decides he's not a
child as well
he becomes a child at the node right up
right above him
so i zero now will realize he only has
one
one child but this guy
believes he's a leaf again after trying
again
to find children and now the done
information propagates all the way up
the tree which is now just this one long
path
okay so they start trying to converge
cast
but then oops they were wrong they have
to make a correction
and that they are forming a new tree
eventually the tree is going to
stabilize
and eventually the done information will
get all the way up to the top
but there can be lots of false starts in
the meantime
okay it's sort of confusing but that's
the kind of thing that happens yeah
so
yeah so the root note isn't going to
terminate until it hears from everybody
you kind of have to close out the whole
process
so it's always pending waiting for
somebody if it hasn't heard from someone
if things switch they'll join in on
another part of the tree
i think the best thing to do here is
sort of construct some little examples
by hand
i mean we're not going to get into how
you do formal proofs of things like this
we don't even have right now a simulator
you can use to play with these
algorithms although if anybody's
interested there
some students in my class last term
actually wrote a simulator it might be a
belt
okay so
all right so that's uh what you get for
a synchronous
some example synchronous distributed
algorithms
so now let's look at something more
complicated when you get into
asynchronous algorithms
okay so so far complications that you've
seen over the rest of this course
um you have now processes that are
acting concurrently
and we had a little bit of
non-determinism nothing important
but now things are about to get much
worse um
we don't have rounds anymore uh so now
we're going to have processes taking
steps
messages getting delivered at absolutely
arbitrary times arbitrary orders
okay the processes can get completely
out of sync
um and so you have lots lots more
non-determinism
in the algorithm the non-determinism has
to do with who's doing what in what
order
okay so understanding
that type of algorithm is really
different from understanding the
algorithms that you've seen all term and
even synchronous
uh distributed algorithms because there
isn't just one way the algorithm is
going to
execute the execution can proceed in
many different ways
uh just depending on the order of the
steps
okay so you can't ever hope to
understand exactly how this kind of
algorithm is
executing so what can you do well you
can play with it but
in the end what you have to understand
is some abstract properties some
properties of the executions rather than
exactly what happens at every step and
that's a a jump it's a new way of
thinking
okay so we can look at asynchronous
stuff if you want from my book
uh now okay we still have processes at
the nodes of a graph
and now we have communication channels
associated with the edges
so now the processes are going to be
some kind of automata
but the channels will also be some kind
of automata we'll have all these
components
and we'll be modeling all of them
processes still have their ports they
need not in general have uh
identifiers okay so what's a channel
okay so a channel is a kind of an
automaton infinite state automaton that
has some inputs
and some outputs so here this is just a
little picture of a channel from one
node to
from node u to node v
so channel uv is just this cloud thing
that delivers messages
it has inputs the inputs are messages
get sent on the channel
so you can have one process at one end
sending a message m
and the outputs at the other end are the
deliveries let's say receive
message m uh at the other end
node v okay
um okay to model this the best thing is
actually to
instead of just describing what it does
to give an explicit model of its state
and what happens when the inputs and
outputs occur
so if you want these messages to be
delivered say in fifo order
fine so you can make the state of the
channel be an actual cue
mq would just be a fifo queue of
messages
it starts out empty then when messages
get sent they get added to the end and
get delivered they get removed from the
beginning
so all that we need to describe this is
a sort of a pseudocode
all we need to describe uh to write in
order to describe what this
channel does is what happens when a send
occurs
and when can this channel do uh deliver
a message and what happens when it does
that
so ascend which can just come in at any
time and the effect is just to add this
message
to the end of the queue the receive
stop moving
the receive
that cannot be construction we'd hear
noise
it's gremlins we have
a receive can occur only when this
message is at the head of the queue
and when it occurs it gets removed from
the queue
so does this make sense as a description
of what a channel does
messages come in get added to it and
then messages can get delivered
in certain situations and they get
removed
okay so that's a description of a
channel in it to be used in asynchronous
system
okay a process the rest of the the
system consists of processes
associated with graph vertices so let's
say p
u is a process that's associated with
vertex u
but i'm writing that just sort of as a
shorthand because u is the
vertex in the graph and the process
doesn't actually know
the name of the vertex it just has like
its own unique id
or something but i'm going to be a
little sloppy about that now
okay so the process at vertex u
can perform send outputs to put messages
on the channel
and it will get receive inputs for
messages to come in on the channels
but the processes might also have some
external interface where somebody is
submitting some inputs to the process
and the process has to produce some
output at the end
so there can be other inputs and outputs
okay uh and we'll model it with state
variables
okay process is supposed to keep taking
steps the channel is supposed to keep
delivering messages that's a
it's a property called liveness you want
to make sure that your components in
your system all keep
doing things they don't just do some
steps and then stop
okay so here's a simple example a
process that
that's remembering the maximum number
it's ever seen
so there's a max process automaton it
receives
some messages m some value
and it will send it out it keeps track
of the max that's a
max state variable it starts out with
its own initial value so x for u
x sub u is its initial value
and then it has for every neighbor
it has a a little um hue
here it's just a boolean uh asking
whether it's supposed to send
to that neighbor okay
um so this is the pseudo code for uh the
max process
what does it do when it receives a
message well it sees if that
value is bigger than what it had before
and if so it resets the max
and it also makes a note that it's
supposed to send this out to all its
neighbors whenever it gets new
information
it will want to propagate it to its
neighbors
so you see how this is written you just
say you know reset the max and
then get ready to send to all your
neighbors
and the last part is just sort of
trivial code it says if you
are ready to send then you can send and
then you you know you're done and you
can set the send flags to false
yeah um for every
neighbor oh i wrote neighbor v before
and then i
yeah i wrote neighbor oh i know why i
wrote w
so here i'm talking about if you receive
a message from a particular neighbor v
then you have to send it to all your
neighbors so before i
i used v to denote a generic neighbor
but now i can't do that anymore
because v is the center of the message
just technical
okay
okay so we we have these process
automata we have these channel
automata now we want to build the system
we paste them together
okay so how we paste them is just we
have
outputs from processes that can match up
with inputs to channels
and vice versa if a process has a send
output
let's say send from u to v that will
match up with
the channel that has send uv as an input
and the receive from the channel matches
up with the process that has that
received as an input
okay so all i'm doing is matching up
these um
components i'm hooking together these
components by matching up their action
names
does that make sense so i'm
saying how i build a system out of all
these components and i just have a
syntactic way of saying
what actions match up in different
components
questions this is all new
okay so when when this system takes a
step well
if there's um if somebody's performing
an action
and someone else has that same action
let's say a process is doing ascend the
channel has ascend
they both take their transitions at the
same time the process sends a message
it gets put into the channel at the end
of its queue
makes sense okay
so how does this thing execute well
there's no synchronous rounds
so the the system just operates by the
processes and the channels just perform
their steps in any order
one at a time but it can be in any order
so it's a sequence model you just have a
sequence of individual steps
um there's no concurrency here in the
the synchronous model we had
everybody taking their steps in one big
block and here it's just
uh they take steps one at a time but it
could be in any order
okay and we have to make sure that
everybody keeps taking steps that
every channel continues to deliver
messages
and every process always performs
some step that's enabled
so for the max processes well we can
just
have a bunch of processes each one now
starting with its initial value
and what happens when we plug them
together with all their channels between
them
in you know for what corresponding to
whatever graph they're in they just have
channels on the edges
so what's the behavior of this if
everybo
all the processes are like the ones i
just showed you
they wait till they hear some new max
and then they send it out
yeah okay um all all across the seats
eventually have a global impact
yep they'll all eventually get the
global max they'll keep propagating
until everybody receives it so here's a
animation if everybody starts with the
values that are written in these circles
um okay so now remember before they were
all sending it once now
no more let's say the first thing that
happens is the process that started with
five sends its message out
on one of its channels okay so the five
goes out
the next thing that might happen is the
other process with the seven might send
the seven out on one of its channels
and these are three more steps somebody
sends a ten somebody sends a seven
uh somebody um received a message and
updated
its value as a result and we continue
i'm
depicting several steps at once because
it's boring to really do them one at a
time but
the model really says they take steps in
some order
so everybody's propagating the largest
thing you've seen
and eventually
you wind up with everybody having the
maximum value the 10.
okay
all right so that's how an asynchronous
system operates
um we can analyze the message complexity
of this uh the total number of messages
sent during the entire execution at
worst
on every edge you can send the
successively improved estimates so
that's again
order n times the number of edges
time complexity is an issue okay so
when we had synchronous algorithms we
just counted the number of rounds and
that was easy
but what do we measure now how do we
count the time
when you know you have all these
processes and channels taking steps
whenever they want
yeah so this really isn't obvious
there's a solution that's commonly used
which is
okay we're going to use real time
and we're going to make some assumptions
about
um certain basic steps taking at most
a certain amount of time like
let's say that local computation time
for a process to perform
its next step is little l you just give
a
a local time bound and then you have d
for a channel to deliver
one message the first message that's
currently in the channel
if you have assumptions like that you
could use those to infer
a real-time upper bound for solving the
whole problem i mean if you know
it takes no longer than d to deliver one
message
then you can bound how long it takes to
deliver to empty out a cue
a channel and how long it takes for
messages to propagate through the
network
okay so this is
it's tricky but this is uh about the
only thing you can do in a setting where
you don't actually have rounds to
measure
okay so then for the max system how long
does it take well let's just ignore the
local processing time
usually that's assumed to be very small
so let's say it's zero
we can get a very simple pessimistic
really
upper bound that says the real time
for finishing the whole thing is the
order of the diameter of the network
times the number of nodes times
little d is the amount of time for a
message queue to deliver its first
message
okay so as a naive way of analyzing this
you just consider how long it takes for
the max to reach some particular vertex
u along the shortest path well it has to
go through all the
hops on the path so
that would be the diameter and
how long does it have to wait in each
channel before it gets to
move another hop well it might be at the
end of a q
how big could the q be well at worst end
for the improved estimates
so let's say it's n times the delivery
time on the channel
just to traverse one channel what i'm
doing is modeling
possible congestion on the queue to see
how long it takes for
for a message to traverse one channel
yeah
are we just assuming that processes
process things and messages are
delivered as soon as they can possibly
happen
um good yeah so and we we normally have
i'm sort of skipping over some things in
the model but you have
a um a liveness assumption that says
that a process keeps taking steps
as long as it has anything to do and so
we would be putting time bounds
on how long it takes between those steps
that'd be the local processing
time here i'm saying that zero so we can
do that wouldn't you be able to like
get some amount of information about
what were things happening
ah okay so here's this is a very subtle
point
so what you think is that if i'm making
all these timing assumptions the
processes should be able to figure that
out
but actually you can't figure anything
out just based on
these assumptions about these upper
bounds
putting upper bounds on the time between
steps does not in any way restrict the
orderings
you still have all the same possible
orderings of steps
so nobody can see anything different
these times are not visible in any sense
they're not marked anywhere for the
processes to read
they're just something that we're using
to evaluate the cost the time
cost of the execution
and you're not um you're not restricting
the execution by putting just
upper bounds on the time if you were
restricting the execution like you had
upper bounds and lower bounds on the
time
then the processes might know a lot more
they might in fact be acting more like a
synchronous
system okay so these are times that are
just used for analyzing complexity
they're not anything known to the
processes in the system
okay all right so now let's revisit the
breadth first spanning tree problem
we want to now compute a breadth first
spanning tree in an asynchronous network
connected graph distinguished root
vertex processes have no knowledge of
the graph
they have uids all this is the same as
before
in the synchronous case everybody's
supposed to output
its parent information when it's done
okay so here's
here's an idea suppose we just take that
nice simple
synchronous algorithm that i reviewed at
the beginning of the hour
where everybody just sends a search
message as soon as they get it and they
just adopt the first parent they see
okay what happens if i run that
asynchronously
i just send it and i get a search
message then i send it out to my parents
whenever and everybody's doing this
whatever they get whenever they get
their first search message they decide
the sender is its parent
keeps yeah not moving not obeying the
fanning property of the vfs
yeah it could be that because we don't
have any restriction on how
fast the messages might be sent and
the order of steps it could be that some
messages
get sent very quickly on some long path
so someone
sitting at the far end of the network
might get a message first on a long path
and later on a short path
and the first one it gets if it decides
that's its parent
then it's stuck this is not an algorithm
that makes corrections
okay so all right
well we before we had a little bit of
non-determinism when we had this
algorithm
in the synchronous case because we could
have two
messages arriving at once and you have
to pick one to be your parent
now that doesn't happen because you only
get one message at a time
but you have a lot more non-determinism
now okay now you have
all this non-determinism from the order
in which the messages get
sent and processes take their steps so
there's plenty of non-determinism and
remember the way we treat
non-determinism
for distributed algorithms is it's
supposed to work regardless of how those
non-deterministic choices get made
okay so how would we describe i'll just
write some pseudo code here for
a process that's just mimicking the
trivial algorithm
it can receive a search message that's
the inputs and it can
send a search message as its output
it can also output parent when it's
ready to do that
okay so what does it have to keep track
of well keeps track of its
its parent keeps track of whether it's
reported its parent
and it has some send buffers with
messages
it's ready to send to its neighbors
could be search messages or nothing
this bottom symbol is just a placeholder
symbol
okay so what happens when
the process receives a search message
just following the simple algorithm
well if it doesn't have a parent yet
then it sets its parent to be the sender
of that search message
and it gets ready to send the search
message to all of its neighbors
so that's really the heart of the
algorithm that you saw
for the simple algorithm for the the
synchronous case so that's the same code
the rest of the code is it just sends
the search messages out when it's got
them in
the send buffers and it can announce its
parent once the parent is set
and uh then it doesn't this flag just
means it doesn't keep announcing it over
and over again
okay so it makes sense that this
describes that simple algorithm
it's pretty concise just what does it do
in all these different steps
okay okay so now if you run this
asynchronously
as you already noted it isn't going to
necessarily work right
so you can have this guy sending search
messages
but some are going to arrive faster than
others
and you see you can have the search
messages creeping around
in an indirect path which causes a
spanning tree like this one to be
created
which is definitely not a breadth for a
spanning tree the bread first tree is
this one
a breath first tree okay so you have
these roundabout pads
okay so this doesn't work so what do we
do
you're going to try to synchronize them
basically
that is related to a homework question
this week very good
we're going to do something different
other suggestions
yeah we could like keep a variable
in each process that so like you can do
something like down and forward
yeah so you can do what we did for
bellman ford but now the setting is
completely different we did it for
bellman ford
when it was synchronous and we had
weights now it's asynchronous and there
are no weights
okay so oh there's some remarks on
a couple of slides here so this is just
belaboring the point that the paths that
you get by this algorithm can be longer
than the shortest paths
and yeah you can analyze the
message and time complexity
complexity
okay so the complexity here is order of
the diameter
times the message delay on one uh
link and um
why is it diameter even though the path
some paths may be very long
this is a real-time upper bound that
is that depends on the the actual
diameter of the graph
not on the total number of nodes
why would the an upper bound on the
running time for this simple algorithm
depend
on the diameter
yeah because you only have a longer
packet that's faster than that
exactly the way we're modeling it it's a
little strange maybe but we're saying
that
something can travel on a long path only
if it's going very fast
but the actual uh shortest paths still
move along at worst at the you know
d time per hop so at worst
the shortest path information would get
there within time d
so something's going to get there within
time d even though something else might
get there faster
okay all right
so yeah so we can set up the child
pointers and
um we can do termination using converge
cast
it's just one tree there's nothing
changing here
okay and application same as before okay
but that didn't work so we're going to
back to the point we were talking about
a minute ago we're going to use a
relaxation algorithm like bellman ford
so in the synchronous case we corrected
for pads that had many hops but low
weight
but now we're going to correct for the
asynchrony errors
all the errors that you get because of
things traveling fast on long paths
we're going to correct for those using
the same strategy
okay so everybody is going to keep track
of the hop distance
no weights now just the hop distance and
they will change the parent when they
learn of a shorter path
okay and then they will propagate the
improved distance so it's exactly like
bellman ford
and eventually this will stabilize to an
actual breadth first spanning tree
okay so here's a description of this new
algorithm
everybody keeps track of their parent
and now they keep track of their hop
distance
and they have their channels okay so
here's the key when you get
new information you receive some new
information this m
is a number of hops that your neighbor
is telling you
well if m plus one which would be your
new estimate for a number of hops if
that's better
than what you already have then you just
replace your estimate by this
new number of hops and you
set your you know to a new parent you
set your parent pointer to the
the sender and you propagate this
information
so it's exactly the same as what we had
before but now we're correcting
for the asynchrony
we get shorter hop paths later make
sense
okay so and the rest of this is just you
send the message okay and notice we
don't have any terminating actions why
because we have the same problem that we
had before
with having processes no know when
they're done
if you keep get getting corrections how
do you know when you're finished
and how do you know this is going to
work in the synchronous case
we could get an exact characterization
of of
what exactly the situation is after any
number
of rounds and we can't do that now
because things can happen in so many
orders so we we have to instead
state some higher level abstract
properties
either in variants or you'll see some
other kinds of
properties as well
we could say for instance as an
invariant that all the distance
information you get
is correct okay
if you ever have your distance set to
something it's the actual distance on
some path and your parent is
correct um correctly set to be your
predecessor on such a path
okay so this is just saying whatever you
get is correct information this doesn't
say that eventually you're going to
finish though it just says what you get
is correct okay so if
if you want to show that eventually you
get the right answer you have to do
something with the timing you have to
say something like
by a certain time that depends on on
the distance well if there's an at most
r hop path to a node then it will learn
about that
by a certain time but that depends on
the length of the path
and um the message delivery time and the
number of nodes because there can be
congestion
okay so you have to not only say things
are correct but you have to say
eventually
you get the right result and here it
will say by a certain time you get the
right result
makes sense so this is how you would
understand an algorithm like this one
okay message complexity
since there's all these corrections
you're back in number of edges times
possibly the number of nodes
and the time complexity till all the
the distances and parent values
stabilize
could be this is pessimistic again the
diameter times the number of nodes times
d
because uh there can be congestion in
each of the links
because of the corrections okay
so how do you know when this is done how
can a process know when it can finish
idea
before we we had said well if you knew n
if you knew the number of nodes you
could weight that number of rounds
that doesn't even help you here even if
you know then
have a good upper bound on the number of
nodes in the network
there's no rounds to count
so you can't tell even knowing the
number of nodes you can't tell so how
might you detect termination
yeah well but even if you know that
you can't count time see this is the
thing about asynchronous algorithms you
don't have
although we're using time to measure how
long its
termination takes we the processes in
there don't have that
they're just these asynchronous guys who
just take their steps they're ignorant
of any
anything to do with time
other ideas yeah can you use the same
convergence
same thing we're just going to use
converge cast again same idea
you just compute and you recompute your
child pointers
you send a done to your current parent
after you've gotten responses to all
your messages so you think you know your
children and they've all told you
they're done
and but then you might have to make
corrections so as in
what we saw before you can be involved
in this converge cast several times till
it finally
reaches all the way to the root okay
once you have these you can use them the
same way as before you
now have costs that are better than this
simple tree that didn't have shortest
paths because it now takes you less time
to use the tree for computing functions
or
disseminating information because the
tree is is shallower
okay so finally
what happens when we want to find
shortest path trees
in an asynchronous setting
so now we're going to add to the
complications that we just saw of all
the asynchrony
the uh complications of having weights
on the edges
right so the problem is get a shortest
path spanning tree
now in an asynchronous network
weighted graph
processes don't know about the graph
again
they have uids
and everybody's supposed to output its
distance and parent in the tree
okay so um
we're going to use another relaxation
algorithm
okay so now think about what the
relaxation is going to be doing for you
we have two kinds of corrections to make
you could have long paths that have
small weight
that showed up for bellman ford in the
synchronous setting
so we have to correct for those but you
could also have because of asynchrony
you could have information traveling
fast on uh
many hops and you have to correct for
that as well so there's like two kinds
of things you're going to be correcting
for in one algorithm
okay so this is going to and this is
pretty surprising it's going to lead to
ridiculously high
complexity message and time complexity
if you really have unbridled asynchrony
and weights
this is going to give you a very costly
algorithm you're going to
see some exponential is going to creep
in there
okay so here's the the algorithm for the
asynchronous bellman ford
algorithm everyone keeps track of their
parent
their conjecture distance and
they have now messages that they're
going
to send to the neighbors let's say you
have a queue because there could be
successive
estimates so we'll have a queue there
um key step the relaxation step is what
happens when you receive
a new um estimate of the best distance
this is weighted distance now from a
neighbor
well you look at that distance plus the
weight of the edge in between
and you see if that's better than your
current distance
just like synchronous bellman ford and
if it is
then you improve your distance
reset your parent and send this the
distance out to your neighbors
so it's exactly like the synchronous
case
but we're going to be running this
asynchronously
and since you're going to be correcting
um every time you see a new estimate
this is actually going to handle both
kinds of corrections
whether it comes because of you know
a mini hop path with a smaller weight or
whether
it just comes because of the asynchrony
whenever you get a better estimate
you're going to make the correction
okay is it clear this is all you really
need to do in the algorithm just what's
in this
this code
okay so that's the receive and then the
rest of the algorithm is just you send
it out
when it's when you're ready to send
okay and then we have the same uh issue
about termination
there's no uh no termination
terminating actions we'll come back to
that
so you know it's really hard to come up
with invariance and timing properties
now for this
setting you can certainly have an
invariant like the one that we just had
for asynchronous breadth first search
you can say that at any point whatever
distance you have
is an actual distance it's achievable
along some path
and the parent is correct
we'd also like to have something that
says eventually you get the right
distance
so you want to state a timing property
that says fine if you have an at most
r hop path by a certain time you'd like
to know that your distance
is at least as good as what you could
get on that path
the quest the problem is what are you
going to
have here for the amount of time how
long would it possibly
take in order to get
the best estimate that you could for
a path of at most our hops
okay a guess
i was able to calculate something
reasonable for the breadth first search
case
but now this is going to be much much
worse
it's not obvious at all it's actually
going to
depend on how many messages could pile
up in a channel
and that can be an awful lot an
exponential number
exponential and the number of nodes in
the network
okay
so here's um
i'm going to produce an execution for
you that
can generate a huge number of messages
which then will take a long
time to deliver and delay the
termination of the algorithm
first let's look at an upper bound what
can we say for an upper bound
well there's many different paths from
v0
to any other particular node so
we might have to traverse
all the simple paths in the graph
perhaps
and how many are there well
as an upper bound you could say order n
factorial for the number of different
paths that you can
traverse to get from v0 to some
particular other node
so that's exponential in n certainly
it's order n to the n
okay so this says that the number of
messages that you might send on any
channel could correspond to
doing that many corrections so this can
blow up your message complexity
into n to the n times the number of
edges and your time complexity
in uh to n to the n times
um n times d because on every edge
you might have to wait for that many
messages
corrected messages sitting in front of
you
okay so you know that seems pretty awful
does it actually happen can you actually
construct an execution of this algorithm
where you get exponential bounds like
that
and we'll see that yes uh you can any
questions so far
okay so here's a bad example
so this is a network consists of a
sequence of
let's say k k plus 1 no k plus 2 i guess
nodes in a line
and i'm going to throw in
some little detour nodes in between each
consecutive pair of nodes
in this graph and now let me play with
the weights
let's say on this path this direct path
from v 0 to v k plus 1 all the weights
are zero
so that's going to be the the shortest
path the best weight path
from v zero to v k plus one
but now i'm going to have some detours
and on on the detours i have two edges
one of weight zero and the other one of
weight that's the power of two
i'm going to start with high powers of 2
2 to the k minus 1 then go down
2 to the k minus 2 down to 2 to the 1 2
to the 0.
okay so you see what this graph is is
doing it has a very fast path in the
bottom
if you'd like to hear about as soon as
you can but
actually there's detours which could
give you much worse paths
okay
so let's see how this might execute to
make a lot of messages pile up in a
channel
okay so my claim is that there's an
execution of that network
in which the last node vk
sends two to the k
messages to the next node v k plus one
so he's really going to send an
exponential number of messages
corresponding to his
corrections he's going to keep making
corrections for better and better
estimates
okay and if all this happens relatively
fast
that just means you have a channel with
an exponential number of messages in it
emptying that will take exponential time
okay okay so
you have an idea how this might happen
how could this node
be k get so many successively improved
estimates one after the other
well what's the biggest estimate it
might get
could get two to the k minus one well
let's see could do that
and it could do that plus 2 plus 2 to
the k minus 2 plus
all the way down to plus 2 to the zero
so you could be following this really
inefficient path just all the detours
before the messages actually arrive on
the edges on the spine yeah so
you follow all oh oh you said two to the
k
minus one parentheses yeah that's
exactly right
that's all right we can't
parenthesize our speech so all right
so the possible estimates that bk can
take on
are actually 2 to the k
as you said 2 to the k minus 1
which you would get by taking all the
detours adding up the powers of 2
but it could also have an estimate which
is 2 to the k minus 2
or 2 to the k minus 3. all of those are
possible
moreover you can have a single execution
of this asynchronous algorithm
in which node bk actually acquires
all those estimates in sequence one at a
time
so how much that work first the messages
travel all the detours
fine v k gets two to the k minus one
then there's a message traveling
well this guy sends a message on the
lower link
so this guy has only heard about the
messages on the detours up to that point
but he sends that on this lower link
which means you've kind of bypassed this
weight of one
so vk gets a little bit of an
improvement
which gives it 2 to the k minus 2 as its
estimate
okay so what happens next
well we step one back and the node from
node k minus two can send a message
on the lower link
which has weight zero uh to be k minus
one
but that corrected estimate might then
traverse
the detour to get to
node vk so if you get the correction
for node bk minus 1 but then you follow
the detour
you haven't improved that much you've
just improved by
1. so this way you get 2 to the k minus
3
as the new estimate but then again on
the lower link
the message eventually arrives which
gives you
2 to the k minus 4. so you see the
pattern sort of
you're going to be counting down in
binary by
successively having nodes further to the
left
deliver their messages but then they do
the worst possible thing of getting the
information
to vk he has to deal with all those
other estimates in between
so if this happens quickly what you get
is a pile up of
an exponential number of search messages
in one channel
and then that information has to go on
to the next node or the rest of the
network whatever it's going to take an
exponential amount of time in the worst
case to empty that
all out okay
so this is pretty bad
okay but the algorithm is correct
and so how do you learn when
everything is finished and how does a
process know when it it can
output its own correct distance
information
how can we figure out when this is all
stabilized
same thing as before so okay
we can just do a converge cast i mean
this is more corrections but it's still
the same kind of corrections so we can
converge casts and eventually
this is going to converge cast all the
way up to the root
and then the root knows it's done and
can tell everyone else
okay okay so a moral here
and you've had a quick dose of a lot of
asynchrony
so yeah if you don't do anything about
it if you just use unrestrained
asynchrony in the worst case
uh you're going to have some pretty bad
performance so
the question is what do you do about
that and there are various techniques
and if you want to take my course next
fall so we'll
cover some of those okay if i'll say a
little bit about the course
so it's a basic it's a tqe level uh
basic
uh grad course we do synchronous
asynchronous and some
other stuff where the nodes really know
about something about time
um here's some of the synchronous
problems some
like the ones you've already seen but
building many other kinds of structures
in graphs and then we get into fall
tolerance
so there's a lot of questions about what
happens when some of the
components can fail or they're even
malicious
and you know you have to deal with the
effects of of malicious
processes in your system and then
for asynchronous algorithms um we'll do
not only
individual problems like the ones you've
just seen but there's some general
techniques like synchronizers
um notion of logical time that's um
leslie lamport's first and biggest
contribution he won the touring award
last year other techniques like taking
global snapshots of the of the entire
system while it's running
in addition to talking about networks as
we've been doing this week
we'll talk about shared memory
multiprocessors
accessing shared memory and
solving problems that are of use in
multiprocessors like mutual exclusion
and again fault tolerance fault
tolerance then
gets us into a study of data objects
with consistency conditions which is the
sort of stuff that's
useful in cloud computing if you want to
have coherent access to data that's
stored at many locations you need to
have some
um interesting distributed algorithms
self-stabilization if you plunge your
system into some arbitrary state and
you'd like it to converge to a good
state
that's the topic of self-stabilization
and depending on time there's things
that use use time in the algorithms
and the newer work that we're working on
in research is very dynamic you have
distributed algorithms where the network
itself is changing during the execution
that comes up in wireless networks and
lately we're actually looking at insect
colony algorithms
where what distributed algorithms do
ants use to
decide on how to select a new nest when
the researchers smash their old nest in
the laboratory
so that kind of question okay
so so that's it for the distributed
algorithms week
and we'll see you next next week is um
security okay yep
whoa